people often ask me what have been my
favorite interviews on the David Pakman
show we've done over a thousand
interviews with something like seven or
eight hundred guests on the program one
that stands out is when I was in able to
interview one of my favorite science
fiction writers Joe Haldeman and I
interviewed Joe Haldeman in part about
his book the forever war which is a book
that is sort of analogous with the
Vietnam War it is the 50th anniversary
of the Vietnam War or at least of 1968
which was arguably the war's worst year
and we are going to go back today to
what is still one of my favorite
interviews that I've done sci-fi author
Joe Haldeman from September of 2014
let's check it out we are joined today
by Joe Haldeman who is a Vietnam veteran
and a science fiction writer whose
best-known work may be the forever war
his newest novel is work done for hire
and as some of our viewers may recall
I've recommended both the forever war
and forever peace to you Joe it's such a
pleasure to have you on thank you so
much for doing this
always glad to do it thanks so let's
talk a little bit first about the
forever war because this was the first
book you you I read of yours
it's from the 1970s how direct and overt
were the kind of allusions to the
Vietnam War that may come from your
personal history in that book was that
deliberate or was it more of just the
natural way that it went I would lean
toward natural rather than deliberate I
mean it was the war that I was in so of
course it provides a lot of the angles
and details and so forth and when you
when you think about the term forever
war in the book of course the reason
that the war goes on for so long is
related to the kind of logistics of time
travel and time dilation but was that
the way it felt with the Vietnam War as
someone who who was in the nitty-gritty
of what was going on I'd have to say
that it wasn't really like that I felt
as if the war wasn't going on forever
but the people
who weren't involved in the war didn't
seem to worry much about it and you know
those of us who were fighting or
recovering from it it was the central
fact of our existence and yet America
didn't seem to think it was that
important at the time
is that the way it felt in other words
we've heard this from others we even
we've even heard from people like John
Kerry who have talked about what it felt
like the perception was from those who
were stateside you felt as though it
just wasn't really being paid attention
to buy them by mainstream America well
in fact the attention was mostly of a
negative kind yeah you know and partly
it's a baby killer a kind of
exaggeration Shannon and the definite
division in the United States between
people who are in favor of the war and
people who both against the war and
against any war including yours truly I
mean I was drafted against my will and
went off to fight somebody else's war
when you put together when you start
working on a book like the forever war
or forever peace when I've spoken to
nonfiction authors they're very very
clear that they have the full story they
have essentially a fully formed outline
or skeleton of what there's their book
will be before they even start writing
it does it work that way with this genre
that you write in or is it a very
different type of process for me it's
different I I do know writers of fiction
who outline to a fare-thee-well you know
they might have 50 pages of outline
before they start writing for myself I
like to get the writing going and let
the story generate itself as it grows
there are all kinds of ways to write a
novel and that's only one that's the one
that works for me are the kind of tech
elements and futuristic technologies and
the like are those often the catalysts
for the story or do you kind of conceive
the story first and then you flesh out
the sci-fi elements that are a part of
it well I've gone both ways actually the
one I'm doing now Phobos means fear
actually came from an article in
new scientists a little article about
six column inches and I thought holy cow
I've got to use that but more often it's
the other way around
and where do you find that your ideas
about these hypothetical technologies
come from in other words are they are
they rooted maybe in an actual science
article you may have read or do you feel
that you kind of conceived them from the
ground up well I guess you'd have to say
they're rooted in my background my
education is in science or other than
literature and you know I I see the
world as a scientist does I think an
objective kind of way so my stories are
colored by that viewpoint as I told my
audience earlier on today's program I
recently finished reading forever peace
and that's a book that was written
sometime before drone warfare as we now
are very aware of it if we're paying
attention to the news is being described
to us when you wrote that I guess I'm
not even sure how to ask this question
when you now hear about what's going on
with drone warfare and I don't want to
give too much away about the book for
people who haven't read it did you have
that in mind are you surprised by the
way drone warfare has now become so
prevalent I was a little surprised at
how accurate my predictions were I mean
I'm a science fiction writer I don't
write as a prophet you know if that
future I described had not come to pass
it would still be a valid view of the
future I mean it's a matter of dumb luck
actually I seem to have projected
predicted how the future was going to
come about but I really didn't expect
that while I was writing it I was just
writing a story and it needed drone
warfare which didn't have a name at the
time I don't think it's very interesting
to me that one of the main issues that
now is being discussed around drone
warfare is this disconnection from the
operator of the drone to the reality on
the ground and through through imaginary
technological means and forever peace
you at least to some extent maybe not to
the plight of the victim
but at least to the idea of being there
you figured out a way to connect the the
drone operator the machine operator to
what's going on on the ground when you
think about modern drone warfare is is
that a concern to you this idea that
there's this physical disconnection that
may make these these incursions almost
video game-like
well there's an element of that of
course now when I was an engineer
attached to the infantry in Vietnam my
main weapon was a radio a radio
telephone with which I could call in
airstrikes and artillery support because
I was in a very small unit just sort of
wandering around in the jungle the woods
in our case and drawing fire from the
enemy and our main weapon was the radio
telephone I so in that way of course
it's a little bit futuristic although to
be honest I first ran into it in records
of world war ii so it was old when I was
born actually when you think about your
early writing when you go back and pick
up and maybe I don't know if you even do
this but if you are too kind of page
through the forever war
are you still satisfied with it do you
what are your reactions to your earlier
work and you know when I go back and
look at a program I did only five years
ago
I'm incredibly self-critical of what was
going on either I didn't make the point
the way I wanted to or I missed key
details or whatever the case may be
what's it like to go back and look at
something you wrote 30 years ago you
know for one thing you have to I'm I'm
charitable with other writers when I
read else's work I said okay he's doing
the best he can right well yeah best way
look at my old work I would write it
much differently now of course I would I
hope I continued learning about writing
but in fact that guy that guy was
writing 40 years ago what could he know
about what is the rapid distance feature
now as I say I have sympathy for the one
I the person I was for two years ago but
we don't feel the same way about many
things that's fair maybe when I look
back at my old shows
just say that's the best I could do at
the time with the experience and the
skills that I had that's exactly it in
fact trying to evaluate your own
creativity it's kind of a fool's game
anyhow because basically your success is
not based on your evaluation of it it's
based on the other people people paid to
read and watch your stuff so you know
you do the best you can then you move on
and do something else the next day for
our television and radio audience we
will pause there and go to a break we
will stay with Joe Haldeman and we will
have more the complete interview on our
youtube channel to talk for a second
about not so much being charitable or
not or criticizing your past work but in
looking at your writing style one of my
favorite authors is john lecarre and one
of his earlier works is the spy who came
in from the cold and that's almost a 50
year old book at this point and he and
he's written a book every couple of
years for more or less the last 40 or 50
years and while the themes of his
writing have changed significantly going
from the Cold War to kind of more modern
maybe a radical Islam etc I can't really
identify significant ways in which his
style has changed over a pretty long
period of time do you think your style
of writing has changed over the last 40
years I know it has I'm a I have been a
writing teacher as well as a writer and
I can be a little bit objective about my
own production and I can tell I made
mistakes 40 years ago that I would not
make now now I'm making mistakes now
that I don't see I know that's true it's
true of every writer but they're not the
same Long's I have a watch the sort of
reaction to my work and as you
I've taken some yeah I don't like being
criticized nobody has what I listen to
it and I try to improve my current
writing from the comments other people
made for from my earlier work are there
particular science fiction writers that
you either read or followed or not
necessarily modeled your work
after but who was it that you really
liked reading when I was a kid I really
loved Robert Heinlein and oh let me see
James Blish and Alfred Bester was a big
one
Arthur Clark of course Harry Harrison
Isaac Asimov all the old guys you know
when I was a kid I ate them up and I
suppose the reason I don't eat them up
now is I guess I become too overexposed
and too sophisticated
I do read some science fiction every now
and then but I don't try to keep up with
it I mean a thousand books a year Jesus
you wouldn't be able to do anything else
have you kept up with it that's
interesting you know I talked to a lot
of people who seem to not whether it's
television radio or books they don't
follow their particular genre or area
very closely and I find this even
applying to me in other words the the
reading I do to prepare for my program
which is mostly news in politics of
course relates to that but my personal
reading so to speak has very little to
do I wonder if there's something about a
thinking about her putting energy into
areas that are unrelated from your work
that in some way kind of helps you
within your own field well I do think it
helps me I I have seen in other people's
writing a kind of a mutual appreciation
society I see people who are influenced
by the same people who influence for me
so I can't claim to be yeah sometime I
am you into this but I I think that you
should watch it you should watch for
repetition in your work you should watch
for influences that maybe were better
left with the previous artists I don't
know what the thing is trying to talk
talking about your own writing is is
foolish and and dangerous of course
talking about other people's writing can
be even worse because people might
suspect your motives this way oh he's
getting paid too much
don't read him yeah I have one question
that I
came up with when reading forever peace
which is in the book you mention a
character reading The Long Goodbye by
Raymond Chandler and that Raymond
Chandler is one of my favorite authors
and The Long Goodbye among his work one
of my favorite books was that of
particular significance to you or was
there any hidden meaning to one of your
characters reading that book you know
the hidden meaning is not hidden at all
to me because I happened to read that
novel while I was writing the book mmm
yes I just put it in there I he's a
great model of course for anybody who
likes masculine fiction not just not
just your honor fiction so yeah my
printer is making strange noises are you
picking them up no and I assure you I'm
not controlling it in any way so it's
not it's not me by any means I think
it's coming from my wife's computer
about 200 yards away so Joe last thing I
want to touch on is art you mentioned
what you're working on now your latest
work is work done for hire can you tell
us anything about what you're working on
today
well what I'm working on today is a
novel called Phobos means fear and it's
a hard SF novel hard science fiction
that is to say the level of science and
it is it's pretty high the main
character is a scientist and she's going
through a sort of late midlife crisis
she's in her 60s and does feel somewhat
it's strange from younger scientists so
in a way it's kind of autobiographical I
think most novelists can't get away from
that trap are there ever days where you
just don't feel like writing at all very
rarely you know in rap in fact it's
quite the contrary
I don't enjoy writing every day but I
certainly don't like days when I don't
write when I'm on vacation supposed to
be having fun I'm going yeah where's my
word processor I should I'm supposed to
be doing something here no question
we've been speaking with Vietnam veteran
Joe Haldeman
fiction writer the forever war forever
peace the newest novel is work done for
hire Joe really a pleasure to speak with
you thank you so much for being on thank
you for having me David